thank you very much president thank you
dear members for your remarks first let
me say that I first I have not said that
everything is fine second I don't need
to defend this commission with words
because I in my quite a long as for me
speech at at the beginning I said very
concretely what this Commission has done
and what we were doing very swiftly and
quite effectively to the to the to the
steel sector in Europe we reacted
swiftly we did our utmost in the three
major areas trade policy industrial
policy employment policy all of them are
a part aware part of the of our steel
action plan and we're implementing them
quite sleeved swiftly in that trade
policy we have tightened our instrument
and we are using them very actively as
much as we can to protect protect our
industry to protect it from the unfair
inputs and and you I showed you the
numbers on Industrial Policy we are
working with our international partners
to reduce global steel over capacity we
are putting a lot of money also with the
new instruments and under the new mff
but also in the car of course in the
current one to innovate and to be to
become for our steel sector to become
more sustainable as many of you
mentioned workers our employment policy
here we have of course primarily a ESF
European Social Fund the global
globalization funds available to retrain
and three skill our workforce to
accompany the many structural changes
that are ongoing in the steel industry
of course the work is not done I cannot
commit on the on the new commission but
definitely in the last year starting
from 14 we put a number of very active
and very working measures to protect our
our steel steel market and especially
our workers let me also mention that the
new commission announced that car bought
both carbon border adjustment tax is an
important instrument for which the
the previous Parliament was was calling
and I think it will be in will be
implemented so no thank you
finding Falcone 7bm Cascadia spy system
it is lawson the next poem to taxable
estate Leland of the president in the
Commission and horn for greater than the
one for the IOC has politic it wasn't
deep or not okay in a vessel a little
Mayo here
Sargon doesn't I will spare him so what
the heck of a history I thought a snowy
system the system it is an emergency
the Cornish and to Melton for bended
bourbon can respond honey about me
living on glory happens to bandwagon he
also visited most other states minutes
Blenheim supreme even TransPennine above
Melinda and highborn can entities absorb
tunes if organize any system into the
whose pockets so button Alden Felicity
knowing colleague uncle Iggy now into
feeling just blow it happened by density
lunamon
commissar M me fool affixing speaking
farmer greeny how come is bad Mukul
iniquity thank you very much mr.
president sir it is a timely
debate in this Parliament gives me a
good opportunity to debrief you on the
work we have done not only in the
Commission side but also on the council
side actually last Monday we adopted in
the Foreign Affairs Council a framework
for restrictive measures in response to
Turkey's drillings in the eastern
Mediterranean this decision makes it now
possible to sanction individuals and
entities that are responsible for
unauthorized drilling activities in
Cyprus territorial sea exclusive
economic zone or continental shelf you
will remember how we manage how he got
there in early May turkey sent a first
drill ship inside Cyprus economic
exclusive economic zone and then another
one in June from the very beginning
there was a common united European
Union position on the matter we acted
the first and foremost in full
solidarity with Cyprus including at the
highest level at the level of for the
European Council with the European Union
heads of state and government then in
July the council decided on a first
response suspending our high-level
dialogues with Turkey
the negotiations on the comprehensive
air transport agreement and endorsing
the Commission's proposal to reduce the
pre-accession assistance to Turkey for
2020 the council also asked the
Commission and the external Action
Service in July to work on further
options for targeted measures in case
turkey continued its illegal drilling
activities we've been constantly in
contact with our Turkish counterparts at
all levels passing messages to the
Turkish side for the need he escalates
and yet turkey decided to continue its
activities and even to move further to
move to block 7 which is an area where
Cyprus has given licenses to a
consortium of EU companies and this is
how we arrived to this week's framework
for restrictive measures as always we're
taking a gradual approach a scalable
approach meaning that sanctions can be
scaled up or down depending on
developments on the ground in this case
let me say rather developments at sea
and as always these are targeted
measures so they will only target
individuals or entities that are
responsible for or involved in
unauthorized drillings our goal remains
to defuse tension and make clear that
cyprus sovereignty and sovereign rights
should be respected in accordance with
international law at the same time it is
urgent to resume substantive settlement
talks aimed at the unification of the
island aimed at the United Cyprus inside
the European Union based on a big
communal and bi-zonal Federation the
European Union fully supports the work
done by the two Cypriot leaders and the
United Nations in this respect we look
forward to the meeting that the UN
secretary-general has come
in Berlin on the 25th of November as a
crucial opportunity to agree on the next
steps towards a solution for the Cypriot
issue European Union has always been
accompanied in these efforts the steps
different stages and will continue to do
so with all the energy and the resources
it can mobilize so hoping and working
there accompany in the UN work for a
settlement making clear that Cyprus
sovereignty and sovereign rights have to
be respected and that the European Union
will always react in a united manner to
defend them and always inviting our
Turkish counterparts to de-escalate and
work in a different kind of environment
thank you